the dmu 60 Evo by DMG Mory is a high-
performance 5axis CNC milling machine
designed for precision Machining in
Aerospace automotive and medical
Industries featuring a swiveling rotary
table it enables complex part production
with fewer setups ensuring exceptional
accuracy and efficiency with spindle
speeds ranging from 12,000 to 24,000
revolutions per minute it delivers
high-speed cutting and excellent surface
finishes the machine is equipped with an
automatic tool changer up to 60 tools
and supports cellos with seamen or hiy
and Hane controls for seamless operation
it's rigid construction minimizes
vibration enhancing stability for
Machining tough materials like titanium
compact yet powerful the dmu 60 Evo is
ideal for manufacturers seeking
Precision flexibility and Automation in
modern production
environments High feed Milling HFM is an
advanced Machining strategy designed to
optimize material removal rates mrr
while maintaining tool longevity process
stability and machining efficiency this
technique employs specialized tooling
with small lead Ang angles that enable
higher feed rates while minimizing
radial cutting forces thereby reducing
deflection vibration and thermal buildup
the dmu 60 Evo by DMG Mory a
high-performance 5axis milling machine
is engineered to fully exploit the
advantages of HFM due to its rigid
structural design high-speed spindle
capability and advanced Control Systems
the fundamental benefits of HFM include
increased productivity through higher
feed rates reduced mechanical stress on
machine components extended tool Life by
Distributing wear across a larger
portion of The Cutting Edge and Superior
chip evacuation which prevents recutting
and enhances surface finish
effective implementation of HFM requires
meticulous attention to machine setup
including the use of high rigidity
workholding Solutions such as hydraulic
fixtures or zero point clamping systems
to minimize movement under extreme
cutting forces additionally precise tool
holder selection such as hydraulic
Chucks or Shrink fit holders is critical
to ensuring minimal tool runout and
maximum rigidity the dmu 60 Evo
high-speed spindle capable of reaching
up to 24,000 RPM enables the use of
small diameter High feed Cutters with
optimized cutting parameters tailored
for different materials including
hardened Steels aluminum Alloys and
titanium cam programming techniques play
a pivotal role in HFM execution with
adaptive tool paths ensuring consistent
cutting engagement reducing tool impact
and optimizing chip load
distribution tool selection is a
critical factor in HFM with indexable
high feed Cutters being preferred for
roughing applications due to their
replaceable inserts and robust cutting
performance solid carbide and Mills with
high feed geometries are also effective
for detailed finishing operations the
specific choice of tool is determined by
material hardness cutting Force
requirements and Chip evacuation
capabilities for instance cvd coded
carbide inserts are highly effective for
Machining steel and cast iron whereas
PVD coded inserts offer Superior
performance in titanium and heat
resistant super alloid aluminum minum
Machining requires polished inserts to
mitigate builtup Edge boo formation and
ensure optimal cutting
efficiency HFM cutting parameters must
be meticulously configured to achieve
Optimal
Performance the typical range includes a
cutting speed VC between 150 to 350 m
per minute for Steels a feed per too FZ
from 0.4 to 1.2 mm an axial depth of cut
AP between 0.3 to 1.0 mm and a stepover
a equivalent to 20 to 50% of the cutter
diameter the dmu 60 Evo spindle speed
typically set between 4,000 to 12,000
RPM depending on the tool diameter and
material properties ensures maximum
material removal efficiency without
compromising tool life in process
monitoring and Tool Weare detection
systems further enhance operational
reliability by allowing for realtime
adjustments to Machining parameters
the advantages of integrating HFM into
roughing operations extend beyond mere
cycle time reduction by lowering cutting
forces the technique minimizes spindle
wear extends machine longevity and
enhances Machining Precision Superior
chip evacuation further ensures
highquality surface finishes while
mitigating thermal EXP expansion issues
the dmu 60 Evo's Advanced 5 AIS control
system enables Dynamic work offsets and
tool center point control allowing for
highly efficient multi-directional
cutting strategies that maximize tool
engagement and minimize idle
movements ultimately High feed Milling
represents a paradigm shift in modern
CNC Machining offering unparalleled
efficiency in high volume manufacturing
environments when implemented correctly
particularly on high performance
machines like the dmu 60 Evo it enables
manufacturers to achieve Superior
productivity enhanced tool longevity and
reduced overall Machining costs the
Strate strategic application of HFM when
paired with optimized tool paths and
cutting parameters ensures maximum
utilization of Machining capabilities
while maintaining stringent precision
and quality standards required in
Aerospace automotive and Precision
Engineering Industries
whe
y
[Music]
PE
d e
[Music]
whe
w
[Music]
d e
a e
[Music]
for
you
[Music]
e e
e
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
for
e e
[Music]
e
pre-finishing is a crucial step in
Machining that ensures optimal surface
quality and geometric accuracy before
the final finishing pass using a D4 4mm
ball End Mill for pre-finishing helps
smooth transitions eliminate tool marks
left from roughing and prepare the
surface for the final contouring
operation
[Music]
he
the
[Music]
finishing is the final Machining step
that ensures high surface quality tight
tolerances and minimal tool mark
using a D4 4mm ball End Mill for
finishing is ideal for precision
applications such as dye and mold making
Aerospace components and high accuracy
machine surfaces proper finishing
strategies help achieve the required
surface roughness raw while maintaining
Machining efficiency
d
[Music]
be PE
PE
e
e e
is
drilling channels is a critical
Machining operation that requires
Precision to ensure proper hole quality
alignment and surface Integrity using a
D6 6 mm drill for creating channels in
materials such as steel aluminum or
titanium requires careful selection of
cutting parameters tool path strategies
and cooling methods to optimize
performance and Tool
life a finished workpiece is the final
product after all Machining operations
including roughing semi-finishing and
finishing have been completed achieving
a highquality finished workpiece
requires Precision Machining strategies
optimized tool paths and strict process
control to meet dimensional accuracy
surface finish and geometric tolerances